[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute einen
klassiker einen maulwurf kuchen ich habe
nämlich auf instagram eine abstimmung
gemacht ob ihr einen klassischen modus
kuchen sehen möchtet und die auswahl lag
dann auch noch zwischen dem klassischen
und der schoko variante das heißt dass
ich die creme auch noch als schokocreme
mache falls ihr das anders sehen möchte
schreibt es noch in die kommentare dann
mache ich noch eine zweite version aber
die mehrzahl hat gestimmt für den
klassiker und daher würde ich mal sagen
leute befangen direkt mal an wir machen
jetzt einen richtig schönen saftigen
schokoladen teig dafür habe ich hier
meinen küchenmaschine und gebt da butter
rein
die butter ist bei mir zimmer war das
ist super wichtig und da gebe ich auch
noch ca eine gute prise salz die hippen
süßen geschmack gebe ich auch noch dazu
und natürlich vanille extrakt und ich
schreibe euch alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben genau
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die butter masse circa
drei minuten lang auf höchster
geschwindigkeit geschlagen jetzt ist die
schön hell cremig genau so wie sie sein
muss und jetzt kommen eier dazu und mit
ihm teilt nicht die eier größe l ich
habe ziemlich ausprobiert das macht
einen unterschied größe es maximal m ist
perfekt die gebe ich das ja aber wenigen
meistens m und einfach rein geben und
noch mal so eine halbe bis ganze minute
schön einrühren
[Musik]
als nächstes die trockenen zutaten
miteinander vermengen das heißt mail bei
kakao und backpulver und jetzt mache ich
so also erstmal sich das ganze
eigentlich nur wegen des bak aus weil
der immer so klimt klumpen reich ist und
bei dem ruhetag mistet ist eigentlich
sieben aber bei cacaus noch ein bisschen
tricky genau und da gebe ich jetzt nicht
alles auf einmal rein sondern immer
abwechselnd mit der milch also immer
schluck mail ich dann wieder trockene zu
werden statt milch und so weiter und
haben sich meine jetzt wo wir gerade
drehen von bayern meinst du mal drauf
kuchen wäre dann lieblingskuchen ja ja
ein bisschen mehr freude hier
ok ok erstmal hier erstmals das machen
und dann okay alles klar
[Musik]
die trockenen zutaten dann nur kurz
einrühren und sobald der teig fertig ist
die trockene die trockenen zutaten dann
nur ganz kurz ein rücken sobald die
trockenen zutaten dann untergerührt sind
ist der teig fertig und ihr bereitet
eine 26 cm springform vor das heißt
einfach den boden mit backpapier
auskleiden das war's und dann den teig
darin schön glatt verstreichen
im backofen habe ich auch schon vor
gehalt der muss auch unbedingt
vorgeheizt sein das ist ganz wichtig und
zwar auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze
und dann packen wir ihn 25 minuten lang
und lassen ihn anschließend zugedeckt
vollständig abkühlen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die füllung und die füllung
des typischerweise aufgeschlagene
frische sahne
wer möchte kann auch einen teil der
seine durch magerquark ersetzen dafür
einfach auch geschlagene sahne
magerquark ein berühren aber ich wollte
einfach auf die klassische art und weise
und ich finde so hat man auch dieses
typische extrem luftige weiche das ist
für mich einfach typische maulburg
suchen ist da wird auch mal zeit so ein
bisschen pepp bei dir heute
ich glaube du brauchst ein kuchen damit
du wieder so richtig aufgelöst wir
machen jetzt hier in einer
küchenmaschine die schlagsahne und zwar
ganz ganz wichtig schlag seiner muss
eiskalt aus dem kühlschrank kommen auch
schiffe gewesen alles kalt dann kann
nichts mehr schiefgehen
ich gebe da schon puderzucker dazu war
extra gebe ich dazu fang anders zu
schlagen und gäbe dann seine feste zu
damit auch schön schnell steif wird und
auch lange steif bleibt
[Musik]
so fertig aufgeschlagenen saale geben
wir dann noch typischerweise schoko
drops einfach unter rühren und dann ist
es auch schon soweit wir stellen die
maulwurf torte zusammen dafür nehmen wir
uns den ausgekühlten boden und legen ihn
jetzt auf eine wunsch dort hatte ich
habe mir ist farblich gold bzw senfgelb
ausgesucht gibt jetzt mein tortenboden
drauf und jetzt müssen wir einmal laufen
aber nicht komplett sondern kleine hand
lassen wir noch ein schneiden aber nicht
durchschneiden also nur ein schneiden
und dann mit einem löffel das innere
rausnehmen und dann zu krümmen
verarbeiten
sollten löffel und dann einfach aus
scham
[Musik]
als nächstes gibt ihr dann halbierte
bananen auf den kuchen boden und da
kommt jetzt natürlich die creme oben
drauf ich persönlich mag so in die
bananen schon richtig reif sind und so
braune flecken haben dann sind die
nämlich besonders süß wir könnten ja mal
reinschreiben was ihre fans seit ich
kann es überhaupt nicht wenn sie noch so
richtig grün sind das mag ich gar nicht
ein dass ich erst mal schön nach seiffen
jetzt gebe ich die creme oben drauf und
dann müsst ihr das nicht glatt
verstreichen sondern eher so hügel artig
[Musik]
und schon ist der maulwurf kuchen fertig
ich persönlich würde noch für eine halbe
stunde kühl stellen damit die sahne
schön sitzen kann und dann direkt
servieren
und er hält sich übrigens drei tage lang
im kühlschrank also richtig gut auch
vorzubereiten
jetzt war es zusammen ich hab dir jetzt
habe ich schon so lange gewöhnt dass wir
zusammen mit peter buck
aber seid froh dass ich ihn gezwungen
habe weil ich finde dass das auch mal
sehr authentisch rüber bringt sie wie
etwas bei drei ja ok 123 ein wärmegefühl
im bauch so richtig denn hat mich an
früher hat meine mama auch immer sehr
sehr gerne gemacht sich auch so
unscheinbar aus und so richtig wollte
den geschmack weil ihr müsst euch
vorstellen haben eigentlich gar keine
schokolade so wirklich im teich sondern
nur den bug hat genau nur den bug
produkts so genau und die schoko das ist
so eine perfekte mischung nicht so süß
nicht zu lasch also schmeckt eigentlich
echt perfekt leute unbedingt nachmachen
ich schreibe euch wie immer alle infos
hier unten in die infobox und dann würde
ich mal sagen haben soll nicht gönnen
und zerstören
inklusive folge gruppen richtig richtig
lecker unbedingt nachmachen und wo
sollen die leute in ihre bilder poznan
für das auch mal sehen
verlinkt mein account dein account
sollten die kurse bedeuten hause oder
bring mir einfach zu uns das gut geht
auch klaren sucht wird dann mal sagen
muss das abstellen zusammen dann würde
ich mal sagen bis zum nächsten mal auch
die sketche
[Musik]